- Take your time, we've got plenty of—
[Explosion]
- Nevermind, hurry up.
- What's going on, Dad? I mean...Andy Reid.
[Zombie attacking, growling]
- No. Sweet baby Nick Foles.
- I think a mutual change will benefit us both!
- I agree! I'm leaving on good terms!
- Yo, they say the kid is special.
- Oh, wow. The world sure is interesting.
What does this do?
- Show him, Pat.
- A high ankle sprain?
But he's still moving.
- I'm immune to bad things.
- We need to take him to Arizona.
- But it's been overrun...
...by Philadelphians.
- Go Birds.
- Wow, another beautiful day in the zombie apocalypse.
- [Together:] Oh, shocker.
You're gonna make us the bad guys?
Typical anti-Philly bias.
- They're connected into one toxic hive mind.
It's very scary.
[Zombie growling]
[Clearing throat]
- Sorry, I'm hometown hero Haason Reddick.
[Glass cracking]
- Scramble!
- Run! I'll block!
- Do you still do that?
- I'll try.
- Aaaah! They sound so weird.
- Woo! Jabroni thought he got me!
- You've been infected...with Eaglemania.
- No, no, I can stop this jawn! I mean...thing.
- He's changing.
[Zombie transformation sounds]
- Hey, Jabronis...go Birds.
- It's Eagle Kelce! Run!
I think now might be a good time to give me some weapons.
Here I am!
Look, I slayed.
- Aaah!
- Illegal hurting of the main character.
- I know it's not cool to say, but this kid is getting annoy—
- This should be a fun level! I mean part.
- Look, they've got runners...
And All-Pro wideouts.
- I thought those went extinct.
[Thundering footsteps]
- A Hurtser.
- Even though I'm a zombie, I'm still very hot.
- Every now and then, you do need some defense.
- Chris Joooooones.
- Damn right, I'm on fire.
- Aaaah.
- [Announcer:] Wow, two young guys making the most of a tough situation.
Speaking of finding love in a hopeless place,
stick around for "Fedra Presents: The Rihanna Half-Fight Show."
- E, A, G, L...
- M, N, O, P.
- A battery?!
- Time's up. Oh, wait...
This watch is busted. Uh, time's yours.
- Tyreek? Tyreek!
If you find this, then I've gone to a better place.
Or at least Miami...hehehe.
I used to hate the world,
But I was wrong.
Because there was one person worth saving...
Me!
I wonder how I write him back!